[Music]
in Apple announcement news oh I put it
I'm not as excited as they used to be no
me neither right is it the credit card
it's submitted by family business it's
the credit card Apple announces a
Netflix style TV streaming app a credit
card in more in recent presidents yes oh
they're coming all the hell is she did
you watch it
I was it like an apple you know thing
keynote who does that now the wife
what know it's like Tim Cook yeah Tim
Cook does it I didn't watch it you I
didn't watch it dr. T no thing was in
September every year yeah yeah but this
is for the Apple this is a press this
was a press event and a lot of people
thought that they were announcing like
new like new iPhones and new stuff that
they're coming out with and so some
people were disappointed that there
wasn't any new like project they are
announcing but they announced four major
new things that are basically
subscription services is Tim Cook gay
he's pretty flamin abuse not to barter
is it why seems like a pretty normal man
does have a scarf some people can be you
know very flamboyant and not be gay I
think he is like my dad's pretty
flamboyant sometimes is he really is
that just Filipino Filipinos oh yeah
yeah the first of all is Apple TV Plus
and so this is what they want to rival
Netflix except they have like a multi
billion dollar budget so they're
creating hella content I like that a
list celebrities so they have like
Jennifer Jennifer Aniston was there
Reese Witherspoon they were all they
were right in the Oprah was there mm-hmm
are all making the announcement they
need to do some Wireless celebrities
like us yeah we could make some movies
for yeah yeah you should talk to them
about it
or one above Z you know what a Z list
celebrity is what a musically person you
just learned about musically and instead
alright I'm behind on everything
it's $9.99 a month which is cheaper than
Netflix and it has all these original
content shows Netflix is kind of not
that cool anymore like started taking on
a lot of like really like weird content
what happened from what I understand
yeah and what's going on the situation
sold you know there's always people drop
in killer apps like Disney because
everyone's taking their stuff off your
Netflix yeah that's what Netflix little
screw ah but that's why Netflix is
buying from creators like Steve has a
movie on Netflix
you're all internet famous you should
check yeah Netflix is switching their
business to producing their own content
yeah they're not licensing also is it
because of necessity it's not because
well both other thing is Apple's going
against their own model that they
created which was Apple starla like you
know I tuned yeah you can't catch the
internet thing like what Apple on
Facebook is you can't catch them because
they will buy you right so they're old
models we are going to buy Netflix but
now they're kind of creating a whole
platform to compete with Netflix so
everyone's going to see if that's gonna
work hasn't worked yet in the tech age
you can't because the user base of
Netflix is so huge it's so huge like
they're never gonna catch up unless you
buy but no but if you think about it
like maybe five years ago everyone was
doing Redbox yeah and and then like red
box got destroyed by Netflix but now
like everyone has their own app yeah
like HBO now that like they have now
like HBO now so all of that fits there
it's not gonna go to Netflix it's not
gonna go so you don't know it's gonna
happen but no one's scared of Apple like
they used to be so gonna have more
because Spotify yeah music music is
nothing yeah so this why would I buy the
song when I gets to remit right and but
they got a streaming service now to
below well have the streaming Steve a
lot not a lot of people compared to
Spotify sure so I've
I use Pandora same you don't use panda i
use i pay for the $9.99 pandora side
though i got friends at pandora shots of
Pandora Oh call me dude I do Google play
music and I have not met another person
that does Google play music interesting
need a brand deal with them like three
years ago and I just like really liked
it yeah so I just kept using it because
they have really good stations and
sometimes if you're like I want to
listen to some leanin music you just put
like clean music and it pops up what
should these Pandora does that - well
Pandora just got sold also so watch out
I know Pandora does that cuz we were
gonna have sex and we're trying to set
the mood and I was just like sex music
and it would make the [ __ ] kill like
the illest [ __ ] playlist it was good
I lasted - can you give me one song on
the sex play yeah oh you know that was
hot okay when Rose was getting painted
okay yeah they have some directors tied
to it - they have JJ Abrams M night
Shyamalan Steven Spielberg they're all a
lot of people but she what's this credit
card okay so that was the first thing
that they released the next thing they
are rolling out is the late they have an
Apple News Plus which so they already
have Apple news right but this gives you
a subscription service to 3000 magazines
to subscribe to them alone you would
have to spend like $8,000 a year on it
but this is only I think $9.99 a month
everything's like $9.99 a month yeah I
know it's like a Netflix but of
magazines but if magazines that's create
explosive deals with time yeah all these
others like that cuz it helps out all
the magazines because it's hard for
people to buy a like down the
over the other one yeah nothing show me
there's a hit on there before I drop the
shows yeah yeah well that's how I
subscribe to Netflix cuz like orange is
the new black came out he has the cards
and it was like this whole how many
something you subscribe to you already
it's a lot this more than my cable bill
guys Showtime stars HBO fight pass basic
cable I got basic cable no one I can't I
can't so cable to cuz it's like I'm
already watching all these others I have
a mom we do it for football yeah we're
her mom watches jeopardy what do you
watch ESPN a we got um play I gotta go I
gotta watch gypsy wedding American Gypsy
Wedding man that's not a longish yeah
TLC loses some good [ __ ] dude you can't
just get the TLC that we probably do oh
okay because I do watch it on something
Apple TV or something I watch it I got
PS view what is that it's like live TV
but it's like you can straight from any
of your tablets and stuff uh-huh through
PlayStation oh alright so the third
thing they announced is Apple arcade
which is a subscription gaming service
subscription basically yeah basically
that what game a little less than $10 a
month actually but because they have it
in pounds here in this article but it
says ten pounds eight bucks ish no ten
pounds is like you know it's the other
way around fifteen dollars like $13 Oh
games on an apple well well it's a lot
of mobile games right like a lot of
people play like a lot of mobile games
I'm not doing they're curating a roster
of games and even getting involved in
the development of the games but you
won't find the games on any other mobile
platform or a subscription service and
they're making them so that you can play
them offline which is kind of cool for
like airplanes and stuff you don't have
to so be logged into the internet like
streaming services if the games are good
yeah what is different I don't know I
don't know any real gamers that game on
Apple well no it'd be like more like app
games app game plans except these would
have zero ads so there would be no ads
on them and there'd be no in-game buy it
oh like you pay the subscription and you
don't pay anything else you just get to
enjoy the game instead of like oh I'll I
need to pay to win Yavin Nintendo switch
how love Nintendo's Wii
now play the cook one what was it
overcooked that [ __ ] gets bigger it's
like a co-op game where you're like
cooking in a kitchen hell yeah it's all
about cook yeah overcooked you got to
play it I got play okay and then lastly
is the credit card there they announced
Apple card which is a credit card for
your iPhone it kind of like goes in
conjunction with Apple pay so basically
anywhere that they accept Apple pay you
can pay with this credit card and you
get points for it so you get basically
Apple cash but put back into your card
that's dope and you get I think it said
2% everywhere that you spend your card
on low hum the daily cash amount is set
at 2% but it upgrades to 3% if you're
spending it on Apple goodies thirsty
right an apple black card well they have
a platinum it's a physical free airline
tickets
like I want [ __ ] like that like you know
the old-school American Express black
card you buy a first-class ticket and
give you one for free the black card
American Express Platinum used to do
that no have you seen a black card
though yeah no I've seen me on black
card
they're trying to use different stuff
that they're not experts at yeah now
they're watering down the thing and now
the computers are in that dough
computers doper no war with Tim Cook I'm
not I mean I got a lot of apple stuff
about to shut down now you're doing
stuff that you not I gotta worry cuz
Steve Jobs died me too
once he passed I'm like did he do a good
job of transferring his brain to
everybody else doesn't seem that way cuz
then someone's gonna rise up and be the
next Apple that's what I think too
I'm still I mean even though I got an
Apple phone I'm not even like hot on the
Apple phone no more it's called an
iPhone Apple phone fine whatever you
know what's annoying their [ __ ] Apple
watch is an Apple watch it's nothing I
know
[ __ ] you a below I love you still though
all the changes they made on their
MacBook Pros there's no out there's no
ports I don't think and there's no port
I wish their announcement was hey guys
we [ __ ] up by trying to make other
plugs exactly we're just bringing back
the plugs
but Apple never since they never go back
on one things their soul never do it
counterculture exactly like we're gonna
change it no [ __ ] you just seem greedy
because we had to buy your [ __ ] we
have to buy this [ __ ] and we'll do it
anyway yeah well they always say like
what every Apple for like the brand-new
design in like yeah there's like little
disciples not brand still it's still the
same it's a neon worst design I wish I
could repurchase my 2013 MacBook Pro but
like with all the upgrades cuz you can't
upgrade it later
you know just I'm just like what some
new [ __ ] like a phone that's a circle or
cycle every phone that comes up is a
sassy brand-new design yeah did you see
this wanna see that that would be a
brand new design I want to square phone
like this like it's like a blackberry
you know I think that's love like that
no I love like I missed a physical come
with the Apple credit card if you did
want to get it I'm not doing well if you
get zero a popper you're thirsty no and
you're out there being thirsty no late
fees no international fees no no late
fees hardly getting their money I don't
know and then there's unlimited amount
of daily cash every day so like
unlimited purchases and stuff I'm
getting everything else Walla no need to
give you like one thing you just give
you a wedding that get everybody like oh
it's so good now that giving you way too
much stuff it's like that store that's
giving you too much you like there's
nothing booboo about this [ __ ] why I
drank the kool-aid I drank the kool-aid
I'm getting in a hospital hold on it
that's why I'm gonna give it a political
card if you want card but not a glass it
no it's just a plastic card it doesn't
have any numbers on it and no security
thing on the back of it but you only get
one percent cash back on the purchases
you make with it and it's really only to
be used with places that don't accept
Apple pay how much interest is that's
whatever it fees or anything what is it
it's just like a debit card no it's a
credit card
in American Express what's your budget
on it what's your what's your American
Express's no there's no limits awesome
American Express I don't know I think
it's a charge card they're just like
yeah here's some money
dudes spend nothing spend it on Apple
you know Apple paid has saved me though
when I got some Alabama what was an
Apple pay it was basically like you
could store your credit cards in your oh
yeah and I was like I forgot my wallet
and I was in the drive to a Starbucks I
was like oh you'll have a Starbucks at
Starbucks app you have a Starbucks and
you should you eat all the points you
know you got the stars yes and I was
like oh
[Laughter]
[Music]